and finally new rules someone has to
tell me what's magic about a capital R
the kind that goes after your name if
you're a Republican because if you have
one of those you can get away with
pretty much anything when it comes to
selling out cursing out or compromising
your own country you know
when it when it was Hillary Clinton with
an unsecured email server Republicans
wanted to lock her up but President
Trump still uses the unsecure Android
phone he had before he got elected and
he has been warned that with an old
consumer-grade phone like that someone
could easily hacked into his twitter
account and start posting crazy messages
and how would we be able to tell
so a couple of weeks before the Super
Bowl Bill O'Reilly asked Trump why he
always defended Putin who arrived said
was a killer
a reasonable question since the last two
guys who were as cozy as Putin and Trump
held their bilateral talks on Brokeback
Mountain
but again Trump took Putin's side over
America saying we got killers here too
you think you think our country's so
innocent if a Democrat said that before
the Super Bowl they would be in
Guantanamo Bay by halftime same as they
would if they did this but if you have
the magic our Trump repeatedly said he
was going to donate to military
charities then didn't then lied about it
he compared our intelligence agencies to
Nazis he said McCain who spent five
years in a Vietnamese prison wasn't a
war hero because I like people who
weren't captured I got to say to all
youth flag-waving right-wingers who
always say I'm not gonna stand here and
let you run down America you're standing
there in letting Trump run down in there
Donald Trump could go to the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier and say well maybe if
he'd done something he wouldn't be so
unknown and Republicans would be okay
with that too when Trump said I could
stand in the middle of Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and I wouldn't lose
voters he wasn't making a joke he's
never made a joke unless his entire life
is some sort of Andy Kaufman style
performance in which case stop it no he
was simply stating in actual fact for
once which is if you have the magic arm
after your name you can drive a Hummer
through a daycare center and Fox News
will say the babies were asking for it
[Applause]
meanwhile in the alternative universe
where a Democrat is President Obama once
said we have not been perfect and for
eight years Republicans screamed that he
was on a non-stop apology tour
they lost their [ __ ] whenever there was
a picture of him committing high crimes
like not having his hand over his heart
during a song or saluting with coffee in
his hand even though this guy did it
with a dog
[Applause]
yeah that guy the one who sat frozen for
seven minutes after being told the words
the country is under attack and
Republicans defended that and we all
just accept this America is the
Republican Party's [ __ ] and they can
criticize and betray her but you can't
even though Obama spent two terms
talking up the troops talking up the
country how much he loved it
how would no other country as my story
even possible
didn't matter conservatives all nodded
when Rudy Giuliani said I do not believe
that President Obama loves America as
opposed to Giuliani who happened to be
mayor on 9/11 so that made him America's
mayor a hero whose great act of heroism
was nothing fell on his head
to paraphrase Donald Trump I like
mayor's who don't let towers collapse a
few weeks ago an old but very smoking
gun emerged from the Nixon era when it
came out that in 1968 when President
Lyndon Johnson was trying to end the war
in Vietnam candidate Richard Nixon was
actively purposefully undermining the
peace talks because he wanted the war to
go on so he could have it as an election
issue you would think that the America
first crowd would find that a bridge too
far
[ __ ] no Dick Cheney once out at his CIA
age and just to say [ __ ] you to her
husband
Reagan sold weapons to her ran the
country they all want to bomb now in
brazen defiance of American law and
instead of being impeached he was
elevated to sainthood and now rides
horses in heaven with Tasers
why do Republicans get away with this
why do they have patriotic immunity
America is like a dysfunctional family
where the democrats are the older mature
son who works hard and does everything
right but somehow is never good enough
and the republicans are the young
[ __ ] son who's a [ __ ] but no matter
how many times he crashes the tomorrow
daddy buys him a new one
I know it's not really important like
which department stores are selling
Ivanka's panty liners you know all of
America's intelligence agencies say a
foreign power tampered with our election
to favor the Republican and they say
also that they don't trust that
Republican our president with our state
secrets and yet the theme of Trump's
inaugural was America first please his
ego was first his hotels are second
Russia's third I'd be surprised if
American made the top ten
[Applause]
you